chin just said I like when you go cuz
you know I'm gonna talk [ __ ] I love this
Bryan's rate talk [ __ ] cuz I'll go he's
got you know what else we do in can I be
honest
yeah never one of us go can I be honest
the money to each other that's when he
gets the best Brennan and I I think it's
safe to say that you and I like we will
tell each other the secrets of the
secrets
oh you know when you know good fellows
when they're on the getting their hair
done their own black eyes and shake it
from their from their husbands yeah
that's us we're not the good fellas Oh
will the wives get our nails done
oh [ __ ] sat beside your brother if you
really needed to hide a body or not
using your my throttle I think so right
Jay's too far I really am probably your
first call my only because I'm um I'm a
I'm your soldier yes right
the only co and it's so funny holds out
nobody else I get a tick I got a text
from you sometimes and I'll just get
this who I got some juicy info but not
for your ears yeah and the only time the
only time I ever called Rennick was we
never talked about the phone cuz what
guys soft for a living I'll [ __ ] I'll
[ __ ] I'll call him and then he
doesn't answer I call him again I want
dude what's going on no you go talk to
you everything all right talk to me and
the best is when you hit me with this
when you go you go
I got info but only only for your ears
in person that's double secret [ __ ] man
I need to know now little [ __ ] tease for
ya like jump in little [ __ ] the teal yo
yo I got new this is a little off talk
but same thing on being in the middle of
the ocean I just had a memory I went to
Alaska with my father and we were in a
what's it called a speedboat you know
the kind of bored with the outboard
motor wheels yeah yeah we were going to
a house boat where there it was a
makeshift restaurant run by this awesome
dude named sweet Eklund I'll never
forget and so we're going in the storm
kicks up and I don't know how to I'm not
a seaman my dad ain't either but he was
a marine and he
he knows how to do boats and he [ __ ]
starts getting super nervous because the
water starts to little choppy
well we're hitting waves likes to show
no colors
oh I'm 33 sir well grown man here's the
problems head in realize I couldn't
stand what my dad was getting really
nervous and telling me to sit in the
back and and he was like getting serious
cuz I was [ __ ] around
as the waves really big and he said but
we made it to the boats but it got
really really scary we kind of just made
it the storm kicked up and I was amazed
at how fast those ways how heavy those
waves were in this little boat so I got
I actually we actually got it was very
dicey and scary we were fine got there
no problem but then the waves really
kicked up and he looked out and he said
in the big vote Mazen get him caught out
there now game over and I said I said
[ __ ] those waves kick that but he goes
yep you have no idea why he was there no
he was nervous because you can't swim
you can't fall in that water it's the
North Atlantic ice cold it's way colder
than you think it's it's you you die in
ten minutes you go into hypothermia with
an exposure suit even in the summer and
it was like I think it was like just
spring we were we were I think was
spring break
I can't member I had a boy a pop was so
nervous dude you know Murray Murray
Murray hey Murray he knows Umberto I
didn't realize that that water is you
get in the water it's a cold I didn't
realize I thought it was just warm do
well in the cold daddy doesn't do well I
call that all had though your dad's
probably well Papa does well because I
don't like Frankenstein
he's got no neck he's border but even
that not Keitel Franklin this minute
humans are not no humans are not humans
are not now in fact I get really mad at
him eating he was eating he's golfing
his age but eating Terry
so to 20 year olds men were arrested
because they went to a McDonald's
drive-thru at like 3:00 to 4:00 in the
morning they got their food came back in
the drive-thru pulled out a gun on the
guy who was working and said that their
that their food was cold and not to play
with them and their food was frustrating
and so the McDonald's worker ended up
calling the police and by the time the
police got there they were still in the
drive-through
and they said that they were just
kidding and that they were playing
around they sound like they they think
things through they get arrested they
got arrested the weapon the permits uh
nope they do not have permits they got
arrested for
yeah pulling a gun out on the McDonald's
worker and also they had some drugs in
the car
crazy talk what smart guys there's been
a string of events where people are just
going apeshit on people working in
drivers do die when they [ __ ] up your
orders [ __ ] is so frustrating if you
weren't mature enough to deal with it
whatever post mates and they forget like
this the sauce that makes the meal when
they forget it Oh bro oh I'm like how
how dude god damn it
poori on I'm not gonna pull a gun I'm
gonna leave you one star review and
you're still another drive-through post
means is different cuz once it's there
there's nothing I there's nothing you do
I have to just but also don't take off
me
everybody knows the drive-through thank
you here's your food thank you i go
through everything check it
thank you oh can I get the bar boom I
don't leave I never check all right
every tied on special tannic people hind
you know it's true everybody waiting
well what's it drive-thru I have the
nice I think it's called me Sophie Leah
it's where the sound of crunching will
ruin my day
my cat was crunching on some didn't hear
it but you mentioned I'm like well that
continues I'm have to leave I was that
take myself out of these so you don't
like if I were chewing crusty bread
crusty bread chips nobody can like if I
go to the movie theater at weird times
like I won't go when everyone goes if
the opening night I'll wait and going
like a Saturday afternoon when
everyone's already seen it if there's
somebody next to me eating popcorn I'll
have to leave the theater that stuck out
it is really oh when they these serve
the vegetable tray plates with like
carrots and celery Rudi's hey what are
we doing
like I gotta leave I can't I can't
participate in know you had that back
this is Hardy at all don't make me happy
cuz I'm reading right now as his pen
clicking - yeah yeah nuts
and you guys sent me so phony phony
phony did they say what it's from uh no
is it a
when I was a kid my dad could evoke I'm
hiking in freedom I my son has my son
has an auditory thing a lot of kids are
blond Daley's yeah so so my son even if
the dog is outside barking my son will
flip the [ __ ] did this they weird me so
feel it comes from me so phony oh he's
so phony why my daughter had to stop me
because I was like sabi and my phone my
daughter's Bryant when he hears things
it you know Brian she goes dad if when
he hears things it's not like the way
you hear things some kids kids grow out
of it but the sounds can [ __ ] kids oh
I've been like this forever though sir
forever than it's just a doll I can is
so feminine movie theater I'll literally
it's all I can hear and focus on than I
have to eating breathe breathing does
drive me nuts
people screaming yep night I don't like
my kid screams I have to do something
about it the brain sites of Miss Ophelia
I suppose I went hunting with Rogan I've
never heard snoring like that in my life
I was like hey Brad do it how's that bro
I started kicking them oh you know Jane
I just hear a room on the road but he
snores and I share a room
no come on anymore oh no no we used to
anymore you have to have to separate
right now you do NORs I can't do it
he snores like a mighty pure quiet some
proms yeah I don't snore man strong
emotional reaction if you have like
anger there's a part of your brain that
just is more active when you hear those
sounds oh man there are some good news
though what's the good news
there's clinic sound listen I cognition
listen my heels been aching for years
I've done nothing about it you family
got a doctor for people crunching in my
now come on bro but I am gonna take you
to Vegas we're gonna get some stem cells
shot in our [ __ ] here about Tim Dylan
Youth on stage asked me last night goes
mean Brent job same diet both kiddo now
do the same
we're both killing it the crowd over so
last night I do a show right so I get
get get who's on the show so it's like
Joe Rogan friends it's Gaffigan
Jim Gaffigan yeah and and then mob sense
you know the second show I go I'll do
the second show cuz I was there I got
there late
and it's it starts with bill burr then
me then Anderson Tina then Bert
Kreischer then go Robin it's not a bad
shot least not a bad Shona winds up that
shows in the world of it yeah
and that crowd was on fire yeah fire
yeah I love Jim Gaffigan we follow each
other on Instagram who is like each
other's [ __ ] and we never met and we're
I'm getting ready to go in the bathroom
I'm all ready to go in the belly room
and the guy run the show goes Jim
Gaffigan is here and we know he's
looking for spots so if he does come up
here he's gonna bump you oh yes Jim
Gaffigan I'll go after Jim Gaffigan he
comes up my god okay here we go he's
going up and Jim goes and I don't we've
never met comes over goes hello internet
friend so buddy
different everyone I was like oh [ __ ]
he's such a legend and he comes up not
that big he's a big dude yeah yeah it's
gonna try and I guess I out white hat
giant dude [ __ ] Midwestern boy but
Santa goes hello internet friend to us
laughing so he goes a little bit about
me I'm Korean I come from Korea he's one
of the best I wish I was from Korea cuz
then my interest in Asian women wouldn't
be so creepy I'm from Indiana I know
you're thinking Indiana mafia he's one
of the better Karl arias it just I could
I could not stop laughing man made my
night hello Internet do you know buddy
you do fall each other but you're not
sure if you really know each other knows
if he's run if I'm running it his wife
is a dialogue internet friend so do you
guys remember a woman bailing are Kelly
out yeah a couple months ago he was
being held and there was a woman who
says that she was his friend and she
actually bailed him out and paid
$100,000 so he would be able to go and
kind of get his businesses in order
before he would get charged and she
really thought that he was innocent and
said he was gonna get out regardless of
whether I put up this bail money or not
and he's a friend so I'm gonna help him
out
and at the time she wouldn't confirm or
deny whether the money was from our
Kelly or from her and now that our Kelly
is not gonna be getting out she wants
her money back and she had her lawyer go
to the judge and asked to have her money
returned to her and the judge is like
Nick don't work that way
yeah because he's got a bunch of child
support money back no she is not and she
knew that upon signing a waiver that's
[ __ ] up though cuz she doesn't and
that's a lot of money for probably this
person why does she do it though she
said that she was good friends with our
Kelly and truly believed that he was
innocent
obviously I get that good of friends but
after she did that her businesses went
down she had a restaurant and a
babysitting business that just went
under well it's a lot of money man it is
like a babysitting business yes I
probably the worst thing has more fear
that's [ __ ] the judge should give
her he's going away for a long time
right very long time well here's the
other thing that documentaries what made
everything pop mm-hmm a documentary on
it was it life I'm not what I mean it
was lifetime I remember when he had done
this with a 14 year old never I was like
why what's going happen right away I
went away
all right paid her off but how the state
is like this is a 14 year old why would
I give that to you as it's a gift it's a
gift it's a gift